I was very surprised I just heard about
it on the less than 10 years ago maybe
six years ago or something like that
about this all these advances in
Neuroscience where they can they have
been able to take the image of the brain
very much but in particular uh these
advances had to do with
some experiments with uh which people I
think his name is Brewer and you used to
be in Yale but now he has his own
company somewhere else
um
there's a paper in proceedings of
National Academy about this in which
they actually
took some monks who were what are are
non-marks I mean who are trained in
meditation
but solid Long training in meditation
not not beginning months
and then he
uh had them
kind of their brain scans while they
were actually began meditation and he
purposely tried different kinds of
medication you know this compassion
meditation there is a sense with such
vipassana Sensational meditations
feeling Sensations and loving meditation
and they tied all those various
techniques and and they found that what
happens is in this on all these
practices is that the
a certain circuit in our brain which is
called DNL or default default mode
Network it's a it's another big circuit
um
that is the circuit that is most active
and we are in normal state
and the way that we hold the world
normally is through an internal dialogue
we are not necessarily conscious of it
but there's continuous dialogue
continuous continuous continuous
argument and it has to do with basically
it's very centered around idea about i
knee mind
yourself I'm basically and what happens
in this meditative practices is that
those circuits quieten down enormously
and
and there are other circuits which are
more related with functional functional
mode circuits they don't slow down
now for most people even though their
all of them are very practice practiced
monks
uh once the meditation they came out of
meditation
then the neurons started fighting and
those the default both networks started
again
but there were few exceptions and these
by the way are the ones who are which
are I first came across this in the book
by
Robert Wright
uh called why Buddhism is true
it's an interesting book I mean he was
um evolutionaries he was a science
writer for evolution Psychology was a
specialty so it still tear quite a bit
towards Evolution psychology and I don't
I don't agree with some of the things
that are said there but it's a very good
book
um and then he reported this and then I
looked up the you know National Academy
of Sciences journal and yeah follow the
reading up here
that there are a few people
who
were in that state even after they came
out meditation
they're always next day
and it seems to me and from the other
things also that we've got some other
time apart that several reasons why I
believe that this is a state of what
used to be called Enlightenment hmm
so it's not a state university well how
you have to go out in the Himalayas
or anything like that
and almost all of them are of course
very deeply practicing mediters and such
things but
it may not be necessary I mean from what
I hear what I write about some other
people I respect and is that it can also
happen
spontaneously I mean
with some effort but don't necessarily
have to have
10 years of meditation or something like
that in order to do this so there are
some mental States so there is a
possibility of actually having this
overlap functions namely science would
say that oh he's no
somehow they were able to switch off the
circuit
and that gave them
and when that happens the sense of self
disappears
and when cells of self disappears then
there is a
very very different perception I mean
this is uh
you know people that that take silos
open for example I mean there are there
is a very active group in Johns Hopkins
who does research on that
um
and again very respect extremely
respected people and very solid
researchers and doctors
they the experiences of those those
those drugs is really exactly that
lately
switching off this the circuit
and
I think somebody said right and what's I
think said with this silent serving This
and like that when you get the message
hang up the telephone which is to say
then you realize that that's such exist
you know don't don't keep taking this
more and more
yeah
so I think that there is enough of work
going on and I'm not saying that this is
therefore going to be solid next five
years ten years my lifetime or something
of that sort but I think it is possible
to reach those States I mean I I really
know some people
whose brace can show that and their
writings
show
whatever they have told me and I have
practiced
I'm very hard-nosed I I don't want to
take any
advisor I'm also not inclined towards
things like devotion bhakti and not
religious person uh but you know I
whatever next complete sense to me I try
to adopt it and this is one of the one
of the principles that we said right in
that
if you want to move towards quote and go
to wisdom you should live by what you
what you understand what you believe
it's not easy it's not easy at all but I
think it is not impossible
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy